hey everybody its Jessie not today we're
going to try to do a masonry layout with
this section sorry wrong phase with this
section so these are all resources
they're going to have images and there
are already different heights and I just
did this kind of ugly workarounds to
keep them all the same height what I
what I was going to do as kind of a
band-aid on this until I got the masonry
layout set up was just truncate these
but I think I'm just going to go ahead
and do the the masonry layout now and
what that's going to do is allow allow
me to use different height cards and not
have to worry about the different
heights and they'll automatically line
up either the right way I know that you
can do this kind of with a width flexbox
the problem is the order of the cards is
weird when you do it with flexbox so the
cards will go like let's say if the list
was one it would be one two three four
five six seven eight nine where normally
you would expect it to go right to left
and then down so any type of sorting
will get will get kind of messed up if I
do it like that so what I need to do is
use JavaScript to position all of these
so I found in the past I've used masonry
so I've used this library and it works
well but I have had I've had two issues
with it that I always have to try to
work with
one if you have images you have to add
another another library called image is
loaded to figure out when the images are
actually loaded and then positional
because otherwise if it tries to
calculate the size of all those divs of
all those little cards beforehand before
the images are loaded they're going to
like stack on top of each other because
the initial size of them is not
corrected too small the other issue of
that is when I've done sites with
reacted in particular with next in the
past when I've tried to do client-side
routing I've had issues with with things
not working so it's possible that I was
setting it up wrong but today I think
I'm going to go with something else so
instead of me trying to take into
account those factors I'm going to use
this library I think this was the one
yeah
so it's react masonry component so this
is using it seen from the documentation
it seems like this is using masonry
anyway so it's still the same library so
we'll still get the same effect but it's
already taking into account some of
those other things and it's already you
know built in react so the thing that's
going to be weird for me at least is
this is different than just like your
basic setup to use masonry to use that
package so it's it's kind of a layer on
top of that so I'm not really familiar
with with some of these options so it'll
kind of take a little a little messing
around with I think to get this to work
right but it looks pretty pretty
straightforward we'll see if we get it
to do what we want and I like that this
is you know react style you know we did
some
some kind of odd stuff for react to get
our jQuery things working so I don't
want to have to do the same workarounds
to get masonry working I'd rather do it
like this you know in a in a style
that's more in line with what we should
be doing in react okay hey everybody I
could see some people were saying hi in
the live chat Cory s would love to be
added to - Jesse Trello you mean like
like the Trello board that I have here
how much sir can you can you add people
I mean I don't have a problem making
these trill Awards public at least most
of them that I have there's nothing like
they can't be public I just want to make
sure nobody can just come in and mess
with the board so if there's a way to
just make them publicly visible I don't
really have a problem linking to that
lemon says please use es6 yeah actually
I am using some things from ESX so
you'll see as we go through I don't know
for sure that I'll be using a lot of es6
stuff and today but I have before and I
certainly will in the future so for sure
I often use template literals obviously
I use let and Const instead of they're
[Music]
using some arrow functions so some basic
stuff you know not really you know you
know complex things but definitely we'll
use some some es6 features also I need
to keep this a little bit shorter than
normal so I've actually set an alarm for
3 o'clock so if you hear an alarm going
off at 3:00 that's because I need to
make sure I get to the store pick up my
son and take him this karate lesson so I
have to get out of here I haven't been
able to take him for a few weeks because
I've been working a lot extra so today
today I need to take them my wife's not
feeling well
so I really don't want to have to call
her later and say can you take him
please
so and today this this is at the first
code that I'm actually writing today
because the day has been filled so far
with so much paperwork that I've put off
for the last few weeks so so let's get
started I'm going to I'm going to move
this let me let me show you at least if
you're not familiar with the masonry
layout I'll show you a demo of this so
this demo is linked from from this repo
and basically you can see the effect
we're going for is that these cards are
all a different height but everything
lines up and I'm sure you've seen this
before
I mean it's this is kind of everywhere
now but it's nice everything spaced out
you know kind of properly as you would
expect right now if I put cards of
different height I would get weird
spaces on even spaces everywhere
just with with the the styles that I
have applied currently so this is what
it should end up looking like you know
everything should and actually we should
we should be able to see this change
okay you see how that kind of just
really fluidly resizes and moves okay so
that's the kind of thing that we want
this one actually even kind of sorts
kind of resource everything so we're
going to have some of that because we
have those tabs already but that's what
we want and let's let's get started I'm
going to move this to my other screen
and I'm going to pull in my my terminal
and actually let's let's move this whole
thing to the screen I don't need it
right now um for my terminal and we'll
install this package and we'll test it
out
first what I want to do
so if you'll notice if you watch
yesterday you know I forgot to get Poole
and then we had to do a merge and I
messed it up and it was it was
embarrassing so today I made sure that I
just did a get Poole right before we
started so we're up to date I mean I
knew for sure this time that I hadn't
added anything in that I needed to pull
but I just wanted to check it out let me
check
I'm going to check the live chat just
for a second and then I'm going to
ignore it for a little bit while we're
setting this up so Jay says you can make
the Charlie Board public so people can
view it but they can't edit okay awesome
so I'll try to set that up then like I
said today I need to get out of here
like very quickly after the stream ends
so I'm not sure if I'll get to set up
today but I'll make sure I write it down
or making it somewhere to do that and
then I'll link to it in the description
mahomes asks why use a jpeg instead of
PNG um usually JPEGs uh I can get to a
smaller file size so that's why I use
JPEG if I need transparency then I
usually go with PNG but otherwise I go
with jpg they always seem to be smaller
I'm not like really an expert on
different file types I just know kind of
basically what you want for performance
on a on a website okay uh recce
I'm sorry if I'm mispronouncing your
name right keyless on says guys what
about you jazz
I don't know that much about UJS I'm
interested in it but for now I mean this
site stood built with react so we're
definitely going to work with react to
this one but I'm interested in learning
more about you okay alright so I'm going
to ignore a lot of chat for a little bit
if you write in the live chat oh I'll
take a look at it at the end and if you
can't stick around till the end for me
to answer you then
put it in the comments for this video or
just direct message me on Twitter and I
will get back to you Oh awesome
Hamza actually I remember you uh I
mispronounced your name a few episodes
ago makes call me out if I do it again
it's Hamza right
yeah Hector my code is and github so
there should be a link in the
description to the code for this and a
link to the to the live site alright so
since this is going to be kind of a big
change and I'm not even sure if I can
get it complete today this might end up
being a two-part thing because since I
kind of have to cut this actually I mean
originally I was one half-hour videos
but they've been kind of getting closer
to an hour every time I'm not sure I can
finish this so maybe we'll finish it
tomorrow so I'm going to do a branch so
if you're not if you haven't used yet
that much you haven't used branches you
can make a branch and get and then it
won't affect your master branch you can
do whatever you want and totally mess
mess up your you know your app or your
site and then just switch back to the
master branch and everything will be
back to normal again
so branching is at least for me since I
work by myself primarily what I use
branching for is if I have something
that like I know it's going to take a
while to implement it and I'll need to
switch back and make some minor changes
on master that's a good good way to keep
those separate so I can you know keep
updating the the main site and not worry
about having this halfway finished code
in there also if I just have always want
to mess around with a new idea and I
know it's going to be a major change and
it's going to be hard to like come back
from then I just do you know do another
branch and sometimes I never really
finish it but it's not really a big deal
to have you
as many branches as you want if if
you're working with a team then branches
are also good like you know I've seen
people they have like their their master
branch is like stable then they have you
know their development branch which you
know you has like a newer version of
things and all the work gets done
primarily on the development branch and
then you know it gets merged in the
master so there's different ways you can
use branches with but but for me I just
you know they're just kind of for
experiments or you know large changes
alright so we're going to make it we're
just going to type git branch and we'll
just give it a name so I'm gonna name
this masonry that means because that's
what we're going to do that way I'll
know what's going on and then I can I
can do I think this will actually list
them for me there we go
so if I type get branch with with
nothing at the end then it doesn't
create a branch it just lists them so I
can see have two branches I've master in
the masonry so to switch to the masonry
branch I'm going to go get check out
masonry okay and now I'm in a Mason
regressor if you see here this this in
the in the green tells me what branch
someone so it was on master now it's on
masonry so now anything I change in this
branch won't mess up master so if I get
a message in the middle of this video
from my boss and he says hey there's an
emergency you know you got a there's
just some things messed up on the site
you can change it I could with one
command switch back to master make the
change or a quick push it and then
switch right back to masonry and I don't
have to worry about that the site is
like halfway broken because I'm adding
stuff to it so super useful I'm sure
other systems like version control
systems aside yet have similar features
I don't really know I've only used get
alright so now that we're on here
I'm going to install that react masonry
component so remember we're using yarn
on our local development environment
instead of just playing NPM I encourage
you to check out yarn it's a I've it's
definitely faster at least from my
experience it's it's faster to install
things than NPM is and the commands are
a little bit shorter so we're going to
go yarn add and we're going to react
masonry component okay I'm just
double-checking make sure I spelled that
right here we go I just had the idea
here not that I would ever do this but
if somebody was really being like a not
nice person they could probably make NPM
packages that were terrible that were
just slightly misspelled versions of
popular packages I don't know me that's
a terrible idea
but people may accidentally download
them so I don't know has anybody ever
seen that happen I okay so we've added
this and let's get and see how to how to
require so we want I'm looking now back
on these the documentation for this and
here's what we want we want to use the
es6 style modules because that's what
we're we're already using so we're just
going to need to import this and let's
add this in let's see where we need to
add this uh so our
our cards themselves are a separate
component it's separate from the page
that they're on so let me think for a
second where we need to add this we need
to add this on I'm not sure if we need
to add this on the component I think it
I think it's supposed to be on the
component so like I haven't I feel like
I say this all the time but I haven't
thoroughly read through this
documentation so so I'm kind of just
going through this and learning as I go
which is pretty much what we do right I
mean I mean most of the most of the job
is learning new things and implementing
them all right where's my card here is
it the text card not a resource card
obviously okay so here's our our card
that we're working with as it is now and
we're probably going to change this a
lot it seems like from the documentation
so first thing we're going to do is copy
that and okay so we're importing masonry
from react nation you component and now
we're going to put in some some of this
markup so let me I'm going to show you
this but I'm going to keep it on the
other screen just so we have more room
to see the code that I'm working on so
if you want to check this out and kind
of follow along um check it out on get
up if you type in react masonry
component just on a Google search this
will come up so you can check that out
and follow along if you need to I just
rather not split the screen up I think
it'd be better to just make this code
bigger and more readable for you all and
I don't need this side so I'm going to
make it
smaller so we can see more okay so some
of the stuff we definitely want to keep
so we want to keep you know the general
look of these cards that we already have
which I think I shown at the beginning
but I'll show again just quickly for for
everyone that's tuned in a little bit
later so this is what we're working on
these are the these are the cards as
they are now so we definitely want to
keep this and for right now I'm not
going to add in the images
maybe tomorrow add in the images but I
know I'm not going to tell the mess with
them now but we will need to test it
with images since they will have images
sometime in the near future but we can
definitely test it with differing
Heights since you know if I hadn't have
set a max I these would all be different
heights right now and the link to that
the live version of this site is in the
description okay so let's try to convert
this component to this masonry to use
this masonry component okay it looks
like alright so if you're following
along with the react masonry component
documentation I'm checking out the
custom prop section just to get an idea
of you know basic the basic you know
kind of how to initialize this it looks
like the component name just needs to be
masonry and I don't even necessarily
have to add any options right now so
here's what I'm going to try I'm going
to try to wrap this entire thing and it
can in an element that's just called Mae
scenery and see what happens
I think I'm gonna have to put some stuff
in here some properties there let's see
okay so we've wrapped that in masonry it
looks like classname my gallery cut
they've given it a class name style and
on clickhandler but I don't I don't know
that those are required I think that's
just you know in there for demonstration
so why not just try it see what happens
so I'm going to save this and we're
going to go back did I move this and
it's my other screen we're going to go
back to this and see how things look
did it refresh I don't know let's see so
it didn't it didn't break anything but
I'm not sure that it's actually using
now it doesn't look any different than
it did before
so it's possible either that I just set
that up completely wrong or and maybe
both my styles that I put in there are
kind of messing this up so let me see
I'm not getting I'm not getting any
errors specific to that so let's go in
and remove the styles from these that
are making them all the same height and
that should give us a better idea of you
know what's going on back side so let's
take out actually this just take out all
of this we don't need it and now I'm
going to save that and we'll go back and
you can see okay so here's what's
happening this obviously is not what we
want but at least it shows us that
whatever we just did with May
is not working I'm going to check the
live chat quickly I always forget to do
this but when I mess something up
usually you own a live chat tell me what
I did wrong and I don't look at it and
it takes me forever to figure it out so
I'm going to check it quickly
okay so yeah remove in the live chat
someone actually let me see by 7:00 I
know you're always watching the videos
when I'm not sure how to pronounce the
ER your youtube name it looks like by
Seba xxxx so is it cool if I say sever
for your name let me know anyway they
said remove Mac site first which is what
I ended up doing so thanks for that
alright so let's look I'm going to
compare quickly the what we have here
compared to what's in the example okay
Sebastian awesome in the lodge cut the
person I was just talking about that I
couldn't pronounce her YouTube name is
Sebastian so I like that name Sebastian
alright
okay so in the in the chat uh let me see
bromo Maddox says when we want one
instance of masonry that has all of the
cards as children instead of every card
being a masonry element I'm not sure
that's a good idea let me let me take a
look again at at this actually you know
what would might be useful
I wonder if hmm I wonder if that site
that had the demo I wonder if there's a
repo for that site I just checked the
sighting it doesn't look like there's a
repo but it's possible that we can
inspect it so here's the inspector for
that site as possible we can inspect it
and go into now it's not it's not
bringing up the option to inspect all
the components that's weird
happens yeah usually I have the option
inspector with react but not now so but
at least we can check this and see how
this ends up coming out it so okay they
do have this looks like the yeah this is
the overall container that they're using
and they have classes on it just like we
have some we have some columns okay this
by this this looks like it actually is
giving some good information I'll
explain what I'm saying here there
column classes are actually on the cards
themselves and our cards are within a
column so our columns are separate divs
and there's part so that might make a
difference so what we could do is maybe
try to make the columns the masonry
components or make the masonry component
be the wrapper around old columns and
not just the the cards themselves yeah
so let's try it and you can tell here we
have these this absolute position these
are definitely the divs that are being
positioned absolutely because these you
know these are being generated and
you'll probably able to see them move
like if I see how that all flashed those
are definitely being generated from
JavaScript okay so let's try that
we're going to go we're going to need to
go out into so let's remove what's
actually we won't need this in here
let's remove shoot that was the one that
I wanted to just this masonry and we'll
remove this down here and we don't need
this anymore and our component and now
we need we want to go to the actual page
that these appear on which is okay I
could have kind of liked it if this
could have been all in one component but
the way I have this set up now it's
going to go here
I could probably refactor later on maybe
and make it all in one component but
just for testing it'll be easier to put
it in here so we can see I have so I
have these right now glowing in each of
these rows is actually a tab so if
you'll check so I have these different
tabs so these will get populated you
know when the page loads and then it
just switches between which row is
visible and which really is invisible so
that's why we have these loops for each
row so I'm just going to test it on
first the first one because there really
is not not I need to do it to everything
before we're sure that it works so
here's our div that I think probably
should be the masonry component um
either this div or it should be
contained in there so I'm actually going
to try to just make this masonry at
first I'm a little skeptical as to
whether this will work but this is kind
of the easiest thing to try so let's
just try it and we'll save that and
check back here all right and
obviously I didn't work I'm sure that so
you caught that I defer got to import
this so let's save it now and see mr.
fresh okay so it looks like nothing new
it's still doing the same stuff I do
want to inspect this and see what it
looks like with the react inspector
okay so I just want to see kind of what
it's doing so we have this masonry
component okay so it's changed makes
your component here and then there's a
masonry container inside of that where
it's actually applying the same the same
class name so I'm not sure if that's
what we want and then the card is is
inside of that okay so next thing I'm
going to try is just wrapping this and
the component I do want to check I want
to compare this to how it looks in the
other side as well let's see actually
this looks this looks pretty much like
what the demo site looked like in terms
of just you know the mark-up is that the
the outer div had the column classes on
it and and look this actually does have
this position set up here so so this is
doing some of what we want so at least
that's that's a good sign right is it
maybe not I'm just wondering where this
height is coming from because I'm
definitely not setting this all right
I'm going to check the live chat again
to see if anybody has noticed something
okay alright so let's try actually I
want to see if we have any change at all
we do okay all right so check this out
did you see that that was like we're
getting we're getting changes so we're
getting a position:absolute we're
getting changes so this is definitely
doing something I'm not sure exactly why
we're not getting what we want all right
let's see okay so these are I just want
to make sure that these columns actually
do have a height so they do so that's
good maybe there's some styles that I'm
applying that I need to stop applying
for this to work I mean honestly if it's
if things are being applied with with
JavaScript you know in line like that it
should override anything that I'm doing
but you know just to be sure
I'd like to hmm I'd like to see what's
going on
let's compare gonna check quickly all
right yeah I'm not getting errors
related to that so that's good this is
from that demo site
I'll shoot no it's not we're going from
the demo psycho
I'll just inspect it again I must have
closed it out so here's the demo side
just to give us an idea of what it's
supposed to look like okay all right I
see here
all right so whoever said sorry I can't
remember right now you said this but
someone in the live chat said a few
minutes ago to wrap the entire thing in
that masonry component instead of each
thing and I think that's probably the
the best way to go from looking at this
now it seems like what's happening here
and this on the demo site this is the
overall container for all of the cards
and it has the same Styles being added
dynamically as each one of our column
classes does this relative positioning
and then inside that we have our cards
being positioned absolutely so that's
that's not what we want so what that
means is we need to go up another level
so that our main container for those
cards is what is the masonry component
and then below that you know inside of
that we have our column component so
whoever said that I'm going to scroll up
so that I can give credit where it is
due let's see
alright bro bromo Matic is the one that
brought that up like over 10 minutes ago
so good call on that and let's let's try
this out so what we want to do is go
back down to where we added this in Oh
mister that we're done for there yeah so
we're down here so let's change this
back to a do and instead inside this I
guess inside the row will work will do
another another element Mason reading
I'm not going to give it any extra
configuration at this point but we
probably will once we once we get it
working we can mess with the
configuration
[Music]
alright let's save that see what we have
oh oh that that looks like what we want
let's mess around with it alright what
do you think it looks like it happened
it works
Wow
um I did not think that we would get it
working that quickly so what time is it
oh wow so under 40 minutes not bad ok so
this is I mean it's working right now
for what we want it to do
right we have different size cards we
don't have that scroll bar that honestly
on on a Mac the scroll bar hides
automatically it's not a big that big of
a deal but on on a PC it like is this
big ugly scroll bar so that was not a
good good
so awesome so that's working so here's
what still needs to happen though and we
need to test one thing I need to test is
if I click around will this still work
because with with the client-side
routing I'm assuming this will since
this is a react component there it's
probably assuming that you're going to
use client-side routing but we can check
that out right now the other thing we
want to test our images and making sure
that it takes into account the height of
the card from when the image is actually
loaded and for some reason okay I
thought my computer for is but I think
my my trackpad is running out of battery
so we'll go back to resources this will
try let's uh now okay
I'm going to restart my dev server
quickly since it's hanging let's make
sure it starts okay
hmm
okay that's where your knows really slow
but hopefully it works now alright so
now we've we've navigated away it looks
like it's still working that was
actually where did you see that we had
this indicator here with spanning two
rows I'm going to click out and back in
just to double-check this go on the the
loading is just taking forever it
doesn't normally take that long I
probably do have maybe I have the
network throttle I don't know for
testing okay so that works we didn't get
whatever that weird thing was so I'm not
too worried about that great so that's
the the first thing that I was worried
about the second thing is the images and
I think I'm going to save that either
tomorrow or maybe if I have a chance to
get it done before tomorrow I move on to
something else since you know the bulk
of this was you know we implemented so
we do have I want to bring bring this
back in quickly before you finish where
is it I lost it I lost my here it is my
documentation anyway so you can see
there's definitely other things that we
can do with this there's different
options for transitions so you know I'll
probably mess around with this uh you
know we even have you know soon there's
a lot of different things that we can do
so maybe I'll mess around with it a
little bit and see but today I don't
have a lot of time so but that worked it
wasn't too hard
I said really the hardest thing was just
figuring out exactly where where to put
this the end of these mace this masonry
um
there so all right so that gives us
plenty of time gives me plenty of time
to check through the the live chat okay
I actually just see one that I'm going
to answer right now at the bottom here
so yes this does apply the question was
this is just applied to the old tab
right now yes and yeah that is true we
only apply it to the all tab so I am
going to have to go in and apply it to
the other tabs hopefully that doesn't
mess anything up I hadn't thought about
that until right now
but I was just assuming that you could
have multiple instances of this and it
would work so that's going to be another
thing I hope that does work out if it
doesn't and I have to do something else
I'll make sure that I mention it
tomorrow whether or not we actually do
it live tomorrow I'll at least mention
if I had to do something different I'll
mention what the problem was and how I
fixed it all right so I'm going to
scroll up a bit to where I last looked
at the live chat and I'm going to answer
actually should I do
let me show you to show you all this
interview first it's only about 30
seconds I'll do that first and then then
I'll get a lot chat that way if anybody
asks any questions they want to get in
you can get it in and we'll have maybe
like 10 minutes to go through and I can
answer some questions so this this video
is from Rick Ryan who does he works with
operation code he actually works at
Akamai the like the CDN company so but
he also does this operation code which
helps out military veterans get into you
know get into coding so I have this up
and make this full screen for you all
and Lacey
short interview but he's going to go
through just like the previous
interviews if you've seen any of them
you know just really quickly talk about
some new technologies he's interested in
and give some advice to people who are
just starting out and learning how to
code all right so my name is Rick Bryan
I'm a CTO of operation covary non-profit
the kids veterans and their families
into programming new technology that I'm
excited about is lick sir I really like
functional programming and like the
paradigm it's fun and sloka challenging
my advice to new programmers is go out
there and build stuff thank you all
right so yeah really short but good
advice actually I like that everybody
that's my last interview by the way from
that I did with people from syntax con
but everybody had really great advice
and and just to add to this advice in
particular just build stuff yeah
definitely build stuff I've been in the
situation before where I've done a lot
of like tutorials and didn't get out of
tutorial mode or stayed in tutorial mode
for too long my thing
where I've done like the online
tutorials and I haven't actually built
anything there's nothing that I could
really put in a portfolio so the
tutorials are really good starting out
and sometimes even to go back to when
you're learning something new but the
sooner you actually build something
you're gonna you're gonna have something
put on your portfolio you're going to
feel really accomplished that you built
something and you're going to learn a
lot of those skills that aren't exactly
covered in this tutorial but you're
going to need you know if you're if
you're doing so you know if you're using
like the in browser editor that handles
everything for you and you go on to a
real job and you have to setup you know
your code editor and your terminal and
all your build tools some places you
know have DevOps people it can handle a
lot for you but if you don't like I
don't have
that here you know you're gonna have to
know how to do all that so at some point
you know it's good to make the
transition and you know start building
stuff and use that so so a thanks to
thanks to Rick for doing that interview
and thanks to everybody at syntax con
who who volunteered and to do interviews
I really appreciate it alright so now
we're going to take at least until they
sit until about three o'clock or until I
get through these questions whatever's
first I'm going to go through the live
chat questions so if you were just here
for the coding then you know you can you
can check out now I won't be doing any
more coding let's see where did I try to
figure out where I left off at okay so
it looks like I left off right about the
point where we were talking about get
branching so Hector says in some cases
cherry-picking with git is useful okay
that mean asks how much you charge for
this website so for this website in
particular I did this at the the place
where I'm employed so I work at a
university and another department was
was starting this project and needed a
website and at some point along the road
it fell to me to do the site so some of
the some of the work for the site was
done basically there was another site
that was built differently
some of the design elements I was able
to repurpose for this site but so
basically I didn't charge anything I get
paid a salary and I work on various web
sites for different departments and
different things that this university
has ads going on I would probably say if
I was going
to charge for this site I don't want to
like I'd have to take into account other
stuff but if I have to give an answer on
this now I would say someone in the end
the chats mentioned five thousand
dollars I would say that that would
probably be the minimum that I would
charge possibly more probably more for
this site because this site is
definitely not finished yet there's
actually a lot more that that they
wanted to do that we're going to add and
right now either there's not content for
or I didn't have time to add it in so
when this when all is said and done this
is going to be a bigger site and it's
going to do more things so I'd be
thinking more in like the ten thousand
dollar range I do some some freelance
work on on the side and the last site
the last site that I did that would have
been like comparable technology wise and
like scope was to this project was over
ten thousand so it was like almost a
$12,000 site so yeah so I would say like
some more than ten thousand range is
probably what I would charge I am in the
United States so I don't know what that
would be in different areas the United
States are different as well so if I was
in a bigger city or maybe on the west
coast
I would probably charge charge more but
I'm not I'm in a smaller a smaller City
and not really a wealthy area of the
country so I think that makes a big
difference to if I'm doing local sites
for local businesses they there's no way
they would pay $10,000 for site it just
wouldn't they just wouldn't have the
money where I'm at to be able to handle
that so but when I do sites for clients
that are outside my area I actually got
a lot of work from people in New York
City then you know that they're not
shocked by a bigger number like that you
know they understand that a good website
we'll take you know it takes time it
takes money let's see have you worked
out so nano Aquila
I think I'm I think I'm saying that
right ask have you worked out how to do
load balancing so you can have one
server running while you update another
I haven't yet I actually talked to so
there's another person in my department
that does web development stuff as well
Brian and he just got back from vacation
today so I was talking to him this
morning about how we can set that up so
I haven't decided on anything yet and
I'm gonna have to try it out I would
like to read up on it a little bit more
but here's what I'm thinking and I'm
gonna have to talk faster if I want to
get through this so if I don't fully
answer anyone's question please put it
in the comments or direct message me on
Twitter because I want to answer your
questions help you out as much as I can
here's what I'm thinking that might be
the simplest solution I don't I don't
know how I would do this exactly but I'm
thinking maybe I have two copies of this
particular site running on the same
droplet on digital oceans on the same
server I already have nginx set up as
the reverse proxy so what I would do is
I would have them both running but they
would be running select the Express
server would be serving them on
different ports okay so what nginx would
then do is split it up between the two
ports and I think this would be more
simple than trying to do it on separate
droplets I don't know I don't know
because the separate droplet would
potentially have a whole other IP
address and then I wouldn't be dealing
with ports I'd be dealing with IPS I'm
not sure exactly how that would work
with you know the SSL certificate so I
don't want to deal with that right now
I'm sure it's possible but I think the
simplest way at least to start out with
since my main concern is just avoiding
down
I'm when I'm updating and I'm not
necessarily worried about like well what
if this droplet crashes like you know
it's not the type of site that like
absolutely has to be online all the time
so at first at least I think I am going
to maybe try to run run two instances of
this on different ports and then use
nginx to switch between the two I don't
know whether or not I'll have to have it
switch like manually so maybe I only run
one and then when I'm going to update I
bring the other one up and manually
switch it or preferably I would like to
have them both running at the same time
and just have nginx like load balance
between the two and so then it would
automatically do it I wouldn't have to
worry about it I don't know if anybody
has any thoughts on that if you've done
something like that before have any
articles or videos that might be helpful
then please let me know alright when I
mention the NPM type of thing earlier
not a mod says he was thinking about the
same thing the other day and he puts a
little devil emoji so nobody go and use
that idea for evil okay okay I have some
advice for when we were working that you
know we actually work through so I'm
going to skip over that but thank you
everybody who gave me advice um if if he
I'm not sure to pronounce that but it
looks like if ëif ie says still learning
JavaScript have no idea what's going on
here with a sad face emoji so yeah don't
worry about it there are a lot of videos
that I watched starting out and
sometimes I still watch them now or the
first time I watched him and like I have
no idea what's going on but I learned a
little bit I try it and then I go back
and watch it a little bit later and I
understand a little more and then
eventually I go back to the video and
I'm like I you know I got all this stuff
so it will happen and ask questions so
I'm happy to explain you know what I'm
doing if the dinging that's confusing
and
looks like also you know it's got some
similar advice for people in live chat
so awesome everybody I'm glad to see the
positive encouragement and I think that
really helps I mean I know it helps me
when I get positive encouragement and it
you know it helps people who are new
starting out as well so it's good good
to throw that around I mean nothing with
wrong with constructive criticism as
well but especially when people are new
I think they mean they need
encouragement more than than criticism
at that point you know they'll they'll
get better that will come so I'm going
to uh my hair I guess that's how you
pronounce it I'm not sure sorry when
when we when you will guys complete the
courses in your website I've been
waiting for a long time um I'm not a
hundred unsure what you're referring to
but I think let me know if this is wrong
I think what is being referred to here
are the free code camp courses like the
new courses so there's there's like a
beta version of free code camp that has
new courses and yeah so I don't know
what the timeline is for completion if
you want to try those out you can I
think there's a get github repo for that
that's up I don't I don't know the link
offhand but you can check that out you
can work your way through the the beta
version so if if you want to get in and
try them out you know they're not like a
hundred percent complete but I can't
lace it I don't know so I can't give you
a definite answer I don't I don't want
to try to tell you something and it not
be correct but and let me know if that's
not what you're talking about um okay
let's see all right I have some there's
some comments here people coming
explaining to me what I was doing wrong
and I missed them when I was doing it so
sorry about that thank you for the
advice okay there we go John Murphy says
I know it's been brought up affordable
what ide is jesse using so yeah
I mean that almost every video someone
asked about the ID which is totally fine
um I don't get annoyed by that at all
because I know sometimes people were
watching for the first time where they
never caught it before so totally fine
if we get the same question but Patrick
Patrick handle down a live chat it is
Adam so if you're watching later on and
you can't see the live chat then the
link is in the description for my editor
it's Adam
it does have some custom um Styles oh
and there's my alarm so I'm going to go
ahead and there's not that many
questions left so I'm going to finish
this out really quickly and then I have
to go the package I'm using the SETI
theme so that's my theme sebastian asks
what packages you have installed so the
theme at least is SETI SETI I do have a
bunch of other packages and I'm going to
do a video soon and put it on on my
youtube channel
about how I set this up really about all
the different tools I use I'm going to
do some short videos on each one so
those should be coming soon I just need
a little bit of time maybe to get in
early uh one day and and do a few videos
so that will be coming and I'll share
that some aim high ass how long have you
been a developer um I want to say like
like five years I've gotten this
question before and I'm gonna have to
like go check my calendar and so I can
give the an accurate answer but I'm
guessing like five years
i-i've I messed with websites and did
like some really basic things like back
when everybody did like tables for
layout and things like that um you know
back in like the early 2000s and then I
didn't do anything with it for a while
but then I got back into it like
seriously you know professionally you
know for money probably like four or
five years ago so that would be that
would be kind of the start
at first when I get into it I definitely
would have considered myself a developer
I was doing a lot of different things
and most of my you know the closest
thing I was going to development work
was like customizing WordPress themes so
for that first like year I was just
learning I wasn't really be doing
developer type stuff but then after that
I got more and more into it and now at
this point my my title is front-end
developer and that's you know that's
what I do
full-time okay so someone's asking I
think based on what I've seen your easy
18 to 20 K all right thanks it R I'm
sorry that wasn't a question they're
stating that so spinnerbait um actually
I think that name is like a fishing
reference so that's really cool why I
like fishing I I don't get to go as
often as I would like but I like that
name um alright awesome thanks so I'm
glad you think that this site is would
be worth that much
bromo Matic ass how did you find a
client for the 10k site I don't want to
give away like a ton of information
about this because just in case like the
client doesn't want everybody knowing
how much that they paid for the site so
I'm going to be like Generic I'm going
to be as vague as possible but still
tried answer question it was a
connection through a family member so
sometimes that happens you just get a
connection
somebody noose someone new one of my
family members and they the company they
worked for needed a website so they got
in touch through social media and and
we're directed to me and then that
that's how it all happened so my best
clients have always been like that it's
been like personal connections or
referrals from from previous clients
that's always the best so I've done
advertising and like all the different
social media sites you know Google Ads
you know I've tried to you know get my
my website ranked higher
are in things and I've gotten very very
few clients from that and usually
they're not big clients so you know
those kind of things are it's good to
have a website and have a social media
presence because people are going to
look at that but the personal networking
is is really where I've gotten the best
clients from and people that I know that
also I've done freelance work before
they've said the same thing so you know
that's that's a good way that's where I
my best advice I can get for trying to
find clients and trying to find bigger
clients is you know try to get those
referrals from maybe smaller clients and
try to work on you know those
connections that you have already and
yeah and then eventually it took me a
while to get to that you know I worked
my way up through a bunch of really
small sites that that didn't pay very
much at all before I got to that point
so it's not like I just you know started
started getting you know bigger sites
like that right up right off the bat
okay so Chad says uh sorry if it's our
guests I just got here but when you do
work remotely what form do you charge
your clients so you don't get skinned um
usually I do something like so I do have
a contract that I give and in the
contract it states upfront that either
the full amount like if it's if it was a
smaller amount
you know if the site I was going wasn't
let's say it's not ten thousand let
sales knowing a site for just a few
thousand dollars which at this point I
don't know if I would take a site for
that much maybe I would against it
depends on the site but cause knowing is
safe for smaller amount of money that
would be more reasonable for a company
to be able to pay upfront they would
have to pay the full amount upfront
before I start working and then that's
like obviously you don't get scammed
right because you get the full amount
upfront and that would be in the
contract otherwise if it's a larger
amount of money then it's usually a
percentage like you know I get fifty
percent upfront what you know whatever
percentage it would be it does depend a
little bit on the total price
and what's reasonable to expect a
company to pay you know based on the
size of the company so I would get a
percentage upfront before I started
working and then I would do the work if
it would be a really long project there
might be some like payment you know in
between like you know once I get to a
certain point the project I get another
payment and then finally I never launch
a site without final payment and that's
in the contract the site the site does
not launch unless I have that money once
I have money then I launch the site then
I hand over all the passwords and
everything but that's how it has to work
otherwise yeah you could definitely get
scammed so that happens I've had it
happen before where clients um I've
never had it happen where a client just
flat-out never paid but I have had it
happen where a client didn't pay for a
really long time after they were
supposed to and I had to like keep after
it and keep contacting them like you
know every week or so for months and
months until I finally got paid and that
was just I didn't like to do that I
didn't like the bug people with um I
didn't it was just a bad feeling to know
that you know somebody was you know was
owing all this money and yeah so now I
don't I don't do that I don't do work
without being paid upfront before the
word goes live so that's what I would
and and if if you get a client that's
not willing to accept that then just
turn them down unless you really really
need that money you know you got to feed
your kids or something like that
um then just turn them down because if
somebody's not comfortable paying that
then it makes me wonder like are they
thinking that they want to back out of
this if they don't like the product like
is that you know why they do they not
want to pay you know they're coming into
this not trusting you that's not a
relationship with a client that you
really want to have so anyway so that
that's my advice maybe some of you might
have more experience
with that kind of thing and you know
feel free to add your ear advice as well
okay spinnerbait says using on standard
port for dev okay cool that's that's
good advice Patrick's been looking into
load balancing lately he thinks that we
need nginx health checks which is not
available in the free version in the
pain version it's expensive okay that's
good to know
I'll look into that um I'm glad you
brought that up because that gives me
some place to start looking at least let
me check the time so okay I can finish
this out there's only like four more
comments here um Zach asks how or where
do I learn the visual design portion of
making websites do you hire someone for
that part or you use do it for yourself
yeah so it depends on what you're into
in what you want to do for me I don't
mind doing the design stuff I actually I
do it myself
and some some people do work like that
and other people they don't want
anything to do with the design and they
have somebody else handle the design
they get it the design basically handed
to them finished and then all they do is
make that design into a real website
okay so I don't have a person like that
working with me right now so I have to
do the design as well I I use Google's
material design standards so that takes
a lot of the work out of it for me um it
keeps the continuity so that I don't
really have to totally think up the
design my you know on my own you know
there are customizations that are made
but I don't mind doing that I definitely
I don't consider myself a designer but I
do things that are you know it's design
work it falls under that you know that
category so if you're into that you want
to do that then you know I would I would
go for it and you'll learn a little bit
about design as well
otherwise you know if you're freelancing
maybe like find somebody that you can
partner with that can you can recommend
to do designs when you try to get with
clients if you don't want to do the
designs yourself and then you know that
could be you know a nice partnership for
you or if you work in a bigger
organization they'll probably have
people go into decides if you want to
just focus on you know developing the
site so but that's how I do the I would
always say I do actually do the design
and development together just myself
okay
[Music]
umberto says often times it happens my
sister-in-law's uncle is Larry heck I'm
not sure maybe I'm not sure what Alberto
was responding to oh okay um the
question before about payment and not
getting ripped scanned by a client Chad
asked that I misunderstood the question
a bit
Chad wanted to know like specifically do
I use PayPal or do you something else so
I give clients the option I actually
assuming the clients in the United
States and it's not a big deal to mail
something I just mailing a check because
you mail a check then there's no fee for
that right at least for me if I accept a
payment on PayPal then they take fees
out so the check is easier for me it's
just as easy as PayPal for me without
the fee but sometimes clients prefer
PayPal so I I do allow PayPal to so
either way I don't think it really
matters what payment method you're using
as long as you make sure that you get
the payment before you you launch
anything and then you'll be fine because
then I mean it's at least get part of
the payment if not all the payment
before you start work and then for sure
make sure you get everything before you
launch a site and then no matter no
matter what you use to receive
if it's paypal of course you get that
money instantly and you can see if it's
a cheque get the check and cash the
check to make sure that they actually
have the money in their account first
before you launch the site so that's a
good point like don't don't just look at
the cheque and say hey I'm going to
launch this make sure you cash it
because if they don't have the money in
their account then you're not going to
get paid even if they wrote the check
more of an asked you use materialized
CSS framework yes I do
I do he's materialized and aim high ash
this is the last one last question have
you got a personal website I do have a
personal web well I guess it's kind of a
personal site so it's just Jesse Weibull
Khan um it's Jay ESS
if you go to that site keep in mind I've
not actually worked on that site for
years so be kind and don't don't think
too poorly of me when you see it it's
just a basic WordPress site that's using
like a pre-made theme there's not a
whole lot of customization going on so
just keep that in mind I really would
like to redo that site one day and make
it like really cool since I'm not really
actively trying to get clients anymore
anyway so that site currently is kind of
like a marketing site to get clients I
just never changed it you know since
I've started you know working like
salary and full-time so one day maybe
I'll change it and just have you know
cool stuff on there that that I like to
do maybe just side projects and things
but for now it is what it is so don't
don't go there looking for inspiration
you won't find it yet um but maybe one
day said you're welcome Jed said thanks
for instant questions you're welcome no
problem I'm happy to do it
um huh man you all snuck in some extra
questions here all right let me see what
time it is
all right maybe I can finish these last
questions and then for real I gotta you
know I gotta leave I got a um pick up my
son and
okay so what are your top Jeremy cos
what are your top three code editors I
use Adam I like Adam I also have used
Visual Studio code and I like that as
well I'm kind of using the two of them
right now for two different projects
that I'm working on and in comparing so
at some point maybe I'll switch I don't
know I'm not I'm not sold on Adams been
my go-to for years so I'm gonna have to
really be sold on something else to
switch just because I'm so comfortable
with Adam and I have all my packages set
up how I like so my third I haven't
really used another editor enough to
have a third one before I use Adam I use
notepad plus plus for Windows I don't
really recommend that it wasn't compared
to like the newer editors like sublime
and Adam and Visual Studio code and what
else I think there's like brackets like
notepad plus plus just didn't seem as as
good as the other ones oh okay
I'm there too made a comment earlier and
I wasn't sure what it was but it was in
response to networking okay I kind of
thought it was so um yeah sorry I didn't
understand that at first okay um
spinnerbait says have a great day later
all right you too
now thanks for watching sublime chesa
sublime man sublime yeah I know there's
a lot of people that really like sublime
I just I've never tried sublime so maybe
one day I'll try it but you all know how
it is if you used an editor for a while
it's just like it's easier to just keep
using that than to learn a new one so it
takes a lot to switch so maybe one day
I'll try it out but alright so I really
have to go now
if I didn't get if you have a question
you didn't get to ask it or you're
watching this later just put it in the
comments and or direct message me on
Twitter or any of my social media stuff
and I'll be back tomorrow same time 2:00
p.m. Eastern and I'm not exactly sure
what will be working on it
depends on how much I get done between
now and then but I'll put it on Twitter
whenever you know just a reminder
whatever I'm going to be live and there
should they'll probably be like an
update if you're subscribed to the
channel that'll remind you all if you
want to watch so thanks so much for
watching and thanks for all the help
that you gave me in the live chat that
that definitely helped me to get this
running faster so I really appreciate
that and have a great day I'll see y'all
tomorrow